il n'y a pas mal des musiciens qui est
bon ce qu'est larcher c'est un
accessoire mais ça marche et le violon
c'est tout petit guide à qui serait donc
un violet sont son marché sérgio chante
ya 41 ans exerce les métiers d'art
chantier depuis huit ans il fabrique
entretien et restaure des archers pour
les violons violoncelles altos et
contrebasse parfois il a de travail
décentes retient de l'entretien des
changes chez les mèches par l'ensemble
des restaurations et ça aussi je le fais
les matins et après je mets quand je me
focalise à un la construction les
musiciens commandes leur archi sur
mesure pour en construire un cerveau
chantier à passe environ 80 heures
dessus
un travail minutieux et qu'il nécessite
beaucoup de patience ça c'est une
blanche de pernambouc d ici je coupe
tout à la main j'obtiens sa route
larcher se compose de quatre parties la
baguette la hausse le bouton est l'écrin
avec beaucoup de matériaux différents
comme le nacre l'argent les bennes ou
encore le crin de cheval
autant de matières qu'il faut savoir
travailler par exemple la courbure de la
baguette il avec un brasseur régulier et
il y avait 40 qui manquent à l'appel
comme ça et ce avant différents jeux en
fait c'est plus stable
c'est plus qui sautent plus haut qu'une
école n'existe pour devenir archetier
sérgio chantier assez fort mais lui au
sein de l'atelier raffin à paris depuis
ou 2020 le quadragénaire s'est installé
à son compte à maisons laffitte
ils cherchent maintenant à acquérir une
boutique pour davantage de visibilité